Whos.
Real wins two-three 2
amendmentdeux-cent-trente-deux
verification vote the vote hatched.
She is Dounia,
and you certainly ask
what she is doing
on the occasion of the elections
European elections that will come from the 6
at 09/06.
We wanted to show you the European institutions
seen from the inside.
So I went to the European Parliament
in Strasbourg,
where I met Dounia François
who is an interpreter.
She speaks 5 languages
and it is in a way the voice of the euros,
French-speaking deputies in the missiles.
in the European Parliament,
it is the passage from one language to another.
A total of 24 official languages for the European Union,
with more than five hundred and twenty
combinations between all these languages.
We make sure to spend many hours
before the provision of interpretation as such,
to prepare
to the specific terminology,
but also, uh,
to the entire context surrounding the key event,
because 1 of the crowns,
I find,
from parliament too,
these are works with many implications,
with many political negotiations for example,
and all that implicit,
it is also necessary to try to
to prepare for it by understanding the context.
And it is
often the exercise of the tightrope indeed,
for
find the right term in French that will make
precisely this concept.
Strong moments in interpretation,
uh, there are some,
and 2 types.
For me,
I would say,
1 moment
history.
For example,
last year,
when
Voldemort zelensky was received in the missicles
in Brussels,
it's a moment when we,
backstage,
here,
in the background,
in the cabin,
we have the impression of
to live 1,
1 moment that will mark history
in terms of interpretation as such.
Um,
it's even uh,
more striking
the moments when I heard
representatives of civil society,
witnesses,
victims
of all 1 series of atrocities,
which come,
uh.
Present or uh
explain what,
uh.
What they experienced in the face of our euro deputies.
Because it's on.
We are in the emotional and we must,
us, as interpreters,
get this message across.
We understand all the issues
and at the same time manage to put himself at a distance,
us,
as people,
because emotions take us very hard,
very strongly and.
And that's it. Me,
it marks me of course.